hi I'm Jim Norton I've never cooked
anything in my life
Gordon Ramsay told me I have to use his
recipe to make scrambled eggs I've never
made eggs so I have the instructions
printed out and I have the video and
went shopping today and I bought eggs
and I bought Pam for no-stick some
pepper some chives I had to buy some
butter and they didn't have creme
fraiche I asked for creme fraiche he
looked at me like I asked for a
fleshlight so I and they said sour cream
can be a nice for placement for creme
fraiche and I don't know if this is
nonstick so hence the Pam this is my
kitchen I had it renovated it's very
small I don't need a whole lot of room
you know because I live alone and only
have a few friends this is my
refrigerator I have some mustard some
Arm and Hammer and this is really my
refrigerators from coffee which I've
never drank in butter which I purchased
today as per Gordon's recipe and this is
my freezer
these are in case I injure myself and I
don't want to tell you what I do with
that and this is the oven I've never
used the oven this cardboard has been in
there since day one it's been a year and
a half look at this these are shavings
from when I moved in a lovely piece of
equipment and this is the unused stove
here are the directions we're ready to
start hope I don't [ __ ] this up yeah
start off with cold eggs
straight in to the pan damn it hold on I
get shavings in there Oh [ __ ] how many
shells are you supposed to get in here
god dammit take your butter three small
knobs of butter from there on the stove
you bring the gas up high and then start
cooking the eggs very gently
every time I stir I'm cleaning the
bottom of the pan now we put the heat on
high weight and we start the timer
stir it for 30 seconds on and off oh
butter now three things of butter and I
just put it on and stir a little bit
for 30 seconds on and then 30 seconds
off my yoke is not breaking isn't it
supposed to break how come my butters
not melting
he said you're cleaning the bottom of
the pan each time each time cleaning the
bottom of the pan this way you don't
want them to overcook there's nothing
worse than overcooked eggs for
undercooked eggs they have to be just
right this butter won't melt how long is
it supposed to take butter to melt that
cut to thicker hunk if we're just season
the eggs now they would go gray so 30
seconds on back off that slows down the
cooking process it stops the eggs from
overcooking now you don't want to add
the seasoning too early or the eggs will
gray a 1:36 off okay they smell good but
it my butters not melting
my butter is melting all right there we
go okay I hope these are how long do I
have to stir these for
[Music]
these are too liquidy where are my eggs
so liquidy check I'm making egg soup but
here's where it goes to a completely
different level take a teaspoon of creme
fraiche goes in that gives a really nice
creamy texture more importantly it stops
them from overcooking well I put some
creme fraiche all right yeah a little
thing of that but that's not creme
fraiche okay a little pepper right
almost ready to eat these are going to
be good in a little while I said I guess
I just stir them until they look good
[Music]
when they do wrong did I use the wrong
pin ah they're starting to come together
here we go let's take them all so we
don't burn them you don't want these to
stick to the pan so this is my own
method of turning this upside down to
kind of push them along see he did it
much faster but I'm afraid I'm gonna get
splatter up in my face oh yeah here we
are
oh boy all right you don't want them to
be too and then we turn the heat off to
be responsible and then
[Music]
I probably shouldn't be putting that
that's where the raw egg was oh I forgot
this little bit damn it chives put that
back there and here we go
[Music]
aha really good I did it
and that's it for this episode of Jim
Norton finally acts like an adult but
these Gordon Ramsay this recipe for eggs
was really phenomenal and this is the
first thing I've ever made in my life
and it's good so let's think I'll be
eating eggs for the next five years
thanks